青木サの100回聞いたら豊かになる話が
ついに100話目まで終了したいうことで
まずは10ヶ月間お疲れ様でした
ありがとうございましたありがとうござい
ました初めての試みでしたのであの
なかなか飲みない時期だったりとかもあり
ましたけどはいはいその場は嬉しい
コメントもたくさんいただきまして
うんうん結はすごく私は楽しかったんです
けどあ社長どうですかあもちろん楽しかっ
たよねまあのこの間ね
3万5人ぐらいなのかなはい今ちょうど
3万6000円をあそうずありいですねえ
78ヶ月でこんなに多くの人にね指示され
てはい本当にあの嬉しく思いますま受行生
のフォローを目的にねスタートした
YouTubeだけれどもま結果的に
なんかもう多くの人にね喜んでもらえてる
みたいなのではい嬉しく思って
[音楽]
ますそしてあの今回実は少し前にですです
ねあの視聴回数のトップ10というの発表
しましてこの1つ前の動画ではですねこの
100話を振り返って青き社長が選ぶま
絶対見て欲しい動画というのを実はあの9
本選んだものを公開していますはい今回は
ちょっと別の角度からですねこの100回
聞いたらゆになる話100はある中で
アチーブメント社員が選ぶ一動画はという
ことで人気投票いたしましたえはいあ結構
面白い結果が出てましてうんうんこう非常
にアチメントっぽいなとええ青木社長がま
経営されてる会社でこう青木社長のま考え
方だったりとか価値観に共感してこう集っ
た社員がま選んだっっぽいなという動画が
すごくやっぱ表を集めてましてええ今回は
あのトップ3を発表したいと思ってるん
ですが実はあのそのトップ3の中にはです
ねあの10万回以上ま再生されたバズッた
という動画がこれまで3本あったんです
けど実は今回このうんとこ3本っていうの
はこのトップ3には実は入ってないとへえ
そうなんですそうなんだそうなんです今回
この視聴者の皆さんにもアメト社員って
いうものいわゆる青木社長がこう作ってる
会社の文化だったりとか雰囲気っていうの
も少しこう体感いただけるんじゃないかと
思ってますうんちなみにどういう動画が
社員選ばれそうるんですかわかんないな
全然ま朝の習慣とかのことも出てくるのか
なああそうですねそうですねうんうー
まあやっぱりま僕は大切なこと大切なもの
大切な人を大切に生きることが人生のま
幸せの鍵だていう風に常日頃社員にも教え
てるしはいま仕事の中に人生を置くという
20代30代の生き方から
やっぱり人生の中に仕事を置くというね
そういうやはりま円熟した人生を生きる
ことの大切さも解いてるのでまそういう
ことに関してのものが上の方に来るのかな
うんうんうんうん
うん実際今回あの投票の中で合計156票
うんうん入りまして実はあの100話の中
で69話に表が入りましたええそれぐらい
やっぱりあのどの動画もま人気なんだろう
と1票しか投じれないので1人の社員が
うんうんうんどれか一押しって選ぶとそれ
だけやっぱりばらけるぐらいには本当に
全ての動画私もあの視聴者の皆様にもご
視聴いただきたいなと見ていただきたいな
と思ってるんですがまその中でもやっぱり
トップ33戦ということで標率多かった
ものを私から発表していきたいとはい思い
ますはいまずうん3位が実は3本ありまし
てうん獲得競争で6票1つ目自分の中に
市街を許容できる器をのある人間になり
たいという願望があるんだよね努力も尊い
けどもっと尊いものは正しい選択なんです
よ瞬間ゆかしっていうのはね器のなさの
照明もうちっちゃいちっちゃい人間
です27番正しさを手放すコツとう
なるほどそして実行しなければないのと
一緒でしょ脇あいあいのチームを作って
仕事をゲームのように楽しんでいく車が
動き続けていくためには動力が必要なわけ
でエンジンをかけなきゃだめだよねそれが
願望なんです
よ同率3位で29は後回しにしない実効力
不全の解消法と私たちがどう解釈しようと
どう捉えていようと普遍的なものがあるん
ですよ多くの人は原理原速から外れて成功
しようとしている自分が何を土台に意識
決定するかだよ
ね原理原則とは何かということが選ばれて
いますなるほどなるほどうんこれも視聴
回数のランキングで言うとそれぞれそれ
ほどこうバってはないようなうん動画には
なるんですけど社員からは非常に好評だっ
たとなるほどいうことで36票ずつを集め
ていますなるほど222名の社員の中の
はい6票集まったわけだねそれがうんまし
たはいそして2位2位がですね7票あなた
はあなたのままでいいその人間としての
存在そのものを受け入れてくれているいや
僕はやっぱりね最後の1日まで若々しく
生きるって魅力だと思うよ弱さから来る
優しさはダメです強さから来る優し
さ89話人間的に魅力がある人の特徴
なるほど
なるほどいうことであのま何が人間的魅力
なのか人を引きつけるものって何なのか
そしてどう磨けば良いのかというのを青木
社長から語っていただいた動画にもなるん
ですけどこれがやっぱり社員からはすごく
人気だったとなるほどいうことでやっぱり
こう人間的魅力アフ社長にもちろん惹かれ
た社員だと思ってますしご自身自身も
やっぱり人間力っていうものを磨いていき
たいという社員が集まってる結果がま反映
されたんじゃないかななるほど私も実は
あのメに内定する前に先行生12人と青木
社長で行く機会がありましてはいったね
はいその時にあの青木社長がま先にご予定
があられるということで中座をされると
いう時にあの退出される時にあの本当に私
の体感地ですけど1分2分ぐらいです本当
に深深と青木社長がこうただの学生ですよ
まだ内てもしてない社員でもない学生に
対して深深とこう頭を下げられてそこから
退出されたっていう姿を見てま当時あの
学生ですのでいろんなこう社長だったりと
か経営者かま会社をこう選んでる中で非常
にこう衝撃的だったうんすごくそこで私も
惹かれるものがあってやっぱりここに
しようて決める一点になったんですけど
おそらくやっぱりこう青木社長が経営し
てる社員だからこそ選ばれた動画なのかな
というのはすごく感じましたなるほどうん
うんそして第1第1位はですねいるよね
まし音だけ人間ねえ
ことができない人は成果出せないし実行
できない人も成果が出ないんです明確な
目的と明確な目標を設定するまずサポート
してください達成まで導くのが愛です達成
っていうのは上司の愛の決勝なの
[音楽]
よ57話のうんまるまるを目指します
まるまるをやりますとこの言ってはいる
けれどやらない口だけで行動しない
メンバーへの関わり
ということであの音だけ人間です音だけ
人間なああなるほどうんうん社内ではもう
この音だけ人間っというキーワードが
ブームになったんですけどこれがあの実は
8表集めました1でございましたうん社長
もこの動画の中であのやりますとやめます
わほぼ同じだとなんだろうま能力図の専門
家としてやっぱりこの意欲と能力の違い
うんえ能力というのは物事を成し遂げる力
と僕は定義しているのでいくら知ってても
思っていても実行に移されないものは今日
もう水宝に奇数そしてやっぱり実行した
だけでもダメでうん成果が出るまでやり
続ける力これ大事だよねうんですま事実
過去ねやっぱり頑張りますやめますという
人間いたからねそうですよねはいはいうん
うんうんであの社員の中ではま音だけ人間
っていうキーワードがブームになったと
同時にまある社員はそもそも私はまず音
すら出してなかったとだからまず音を出す
時から始めますということで音はまず出し
てみるとなるほどこれをやりますと宣言し
て実際あの達成している社員もたくさん
いらっしゃいましたので社員の中では
ブーム1台ブームを引き起こしたキー
ワードがやっぱり刺さってましたね
なるほどなるほど赤字は話も刺さってまし
たけどねそうだねいやでも事実そうなんだ
ようん世の中ってさ経者として赤字という
ことに対して危機感を持ってない人多いよ
ねうん赤字は鼻血と一緒で出続けたら死ん
じゃうよっっていうフレーズなはいこれ
結構響いたんじゃないはい響いてました
いやそうだと思いますようんうんま僕は
もうプライド持ってずっとねやっぱり黒字
系を維持してきたんでうんま創業の最初の
ね数年間苦しい時代があったけれどもはい
やっぱり入りのバランスを取りながらはい
長期的においても短期的においても
しっかりと成果を出し続け成果を出し
続けるからこそ税引を利益の3割を社員に
分配できるわけでやっぱりその愛というの
を中概念ではなく物心両面の豊かな人生を
具体的にこう提供していける強さを僕は
経営者として追求してきたからね実践値と
いうかうんそこがま私のま新骨張かもしれ
ないよねはい
[音楽]
うんそれと同士に今回あのランキング
改めて振り返ると1位が57話のままを
目指しますままやります口先だけで行動し
ないメンバーへの関わり方そして2位が
89話の人間的に魅力がある人の特徴そ
同率3位で正しさを手放すコツ後回しにし
ない実効力不全の解消法そして90は原理
原則とは何かということでこの青ピシ長の
やっぱりこう絶対に黒字にする赤字にはし
ない行動で完結するというのがこの1位の
テーマだったりとかあとは後回しにしない
自己力不全の解消法ということでこの
やっぱり強さうんがすごく社員にもってる
んだろうなと思いますしと同時にこの
なんて言うんでしょ正しさを手放すつまり
このなんか強さだけを主張するではなくて
この正しさを押し付けるのではなくて需要
するそれがまさにこの2位の人間力に
つがってくるところなのかなというのも
思いましてこの社長のなんて言うん
でしょう良きと言いますか強さとま譲渡が
こうシナジーが生まれているような経営が
こう表されてる結果なのかなと私は思った
んですがいかがでしたこのランキングをり
そうだねやっぱりま私のYouTube
1番ね社員が見てて社長は言ってること
やってることが一貫性あるかどうかっての
1番ぱ身近な人に222名の正社員って
ことはその倍の目玉がねやっぱり僕を
ずっと観察してるわけだからそこが一貫性
があればさらにリスペクトが高まるだろう
しそうでなければ下がるわけだからまこう
いったyoubeをするということもね
ある意味ではチャレンジだよねうんただ僕
はま本音本心本気これをもっとにしてるの
で社員の前ではこういうこと言ってここで
はこういうこと言うってことはないので
あの今のなんて言うのかな人気のこう見る
と僕の大切にしてることを彼ら分かって
くれてるんだなと再確にてきましたうん
本当にそうます社員が選んだなっていうの
をすごく感じるランキングでそう思います
はいこれはあれですね視聴者の皆さんにも
ちょっと聞いてみたいですね一押し動画
そうだねまどんなねなんだろう一押し動が
出てくるのかね1回今度機会見て聞いてみ
ましょうはい是非うんあの視聴者の方もね
え是非あのコメント欄に投票の順位が出る
ところがありますから是非そこにですねえ
票ししていただきたいと思いますはいはい
ありがとうございます